hi there today we'll talk about switch
transformers scaling to trillion
parameter models with
simple and efficient sparsity by william
fetus
barrett zoff and noam shazier of google
brain
so as you can see right off the title
we're going towards
trillions of parameters gpt3 had 175
billion parameters
this paper claims to have a model with a
trillion parameters
now is it really five times bigger or
ten times bigger than gpt3
that's a debatable question because the
trillion parameters are not used in the
same way as in a classic transformers
uh they are used actually in a sparse
way that's why the word
sparsity is in here
and the way they are used in sparse
manner
is this new architecture called the
switch transformer
it's not entirely new the it's built on
mixture of
experts uh in this paper that's also
called m-o-e
that has been around for a while and
we're going to see what that is
now on a high level switch transformers
takes
mixture of experts to an extreme in that
it is a transformer
um and the feed forward layer
is divided up into these experts and
the switch transformer only routes each
token to
one expert only that's the sparse part
so the mixture of experts previously
they always claimed you need at least
two experts in order to get a stable
training signal
the switch transformer manages to get it
down to a single
expert so it's like a hard routing of
information
to just a single endpoint per layer of
each token
so in that that means you can now scale
the experts
and you can scale the number of
parameters
in the model without making the model
compute more
that's a very special notion so you can
up the parameters of the model
but if a forward pass of a data point
will still have the same amount of flops
that it needs to forward propagate
through the network
very special architecture right here so
yeah that's why i'm saying trillion
parameters not necessarily
comparable to the 175 billion parameters
of something like gpt3
so how do they do it because previously
was
claimed it was unstable they have new
ways of making the training stable such
as selective dropout
selective casting of parameters to
different precisions
and a better initialization so
that's the high level overview of the
paper and
we'll dive into it we'll explore kind of
what mixture of experts is
and how the model works and what turns
out it's a very long paper as you can
see when papers have a table of
uh that's a lot of fun uh but it's
a lot of engineering as well and we're
mostly interested in
the model here what it can do and what
does it
how does it sort of fit in to the
big world of transformers and language
models and so on
last thing i want to say trillion
parameters
is you know it's a catchy title
that most of the paper they don't work
with trillion parameter models they work
with models
in the in the order of billions of
parameters and
at the end they build a model with a
trillion parameters
it doesn't do as well as their models
with in as their smaller models uh they
also
it feels like they don't put that much
you know work into it because it's
probably also quite
uh fuzzy and expensive but just know
we're not going to have trillion
parameter models around anytime
soon just yet
interesting fact the original resnet
paper also built a
1 000 layer convolutional neural network
even though the resnets we have today
you know
they are maybe 50 or 150 layers
deep they did build a thousand layer
model
so maybe compare it a bit to that one
it's just like we can do it
not necessarily we need to so here you
can see
something they discover the curve on the
left
is very very known to people that are in
the
language model game let's say or in the
in the let's
scale up ai game and that is
as you increase the size of the model
the loss will go down
and that's loss as i understand it so
that's test loss
um i believe that is perplexity
so scaling properties exactly that that
might be perplexity or test loss on some
uh downstream task in any way as you
scale up
the model parameters the model gets
better and better
and better the interesting thing right
here is twofold
first of all i believe they do hold the
data set
constant so the data set is always the
same the amount of
compute you put into it the amount of
either number of steps or time is
also always the same and in this
specific case the amount of flops
per forward pass is also the same the
only thing that changes
is the number of parameters again it's
very special to have a model
where you can scale up the number of
parameters
yet the flops required to forward
propagates stay the same so you can see
here that there is
a almost unhalted decrease here
it flattens out a little bit towards the
bottom though that is not necessarily
does not necessarily mean it will ever
flatten out before it's
you know at zero um i will approach
zero i guess so and you can you can see
that
you know they scale up the model quite a
bit and also
their main comparison here is the t5
base
so that's the text to text transfer
transformer
by the way if you don't know what a
transformer is or what a language model
is
um it's best you you go back to my
earlier videos
and look up like the the gpt3
paper or the attention is all you need
paper i've made videos about lots of
these
things i assume that you know them you
can see right here that if you compare
to number of training steps for example
the these switch models
all of them no matter how big they are
they provide
massive gains over like something like a
t5
and they also do this in time
so this paper is very much about
trade-offs
you do require more storage
for your weights so you have to have
more
memory more ram however that memory
can be distributed it can be sharded
because they use this mesh tensorflow
library to implement the switch
transformers
and because their model has this
sparsity
they can efficiently shard the model
so you trade off more memory which can
be shorted
but what you gain is training speed
in both in terms of time and number of
training steps required
so you are much more efficient note that
this only
all of this holds in this super large
regime right
we this is they say they've also
discovered these speed ups in smaller
models
but you know as far as the paper is
concerned we are talking about
millions hundreds of millions of
parameters billions of parameters
even to trillion of parameters together
with these
giant corp corpora of of text
so that's sort of the regime we are in
and
the results do not necessarily transfer
down
to the lower scale problems that
you know you might face with your lonely
one
colab in the corner all right
so in a transformer you have
a transformer is nothing else but a
bunch of these layers right here
this is this is in in itself a
transformer
layer uh in its basic form and it
consists of
sort of two parts it consists of this
self attention
right here now that's the standard
transformer
self attention that's the what was
introduced in attention is all you need
and what's been
used ever since in all the transformers
um this one right here is a
is an uh as i understand it a language
model
so you know this this is very standard
however after the self attention you
have this
feed forward layer now usually
what you do is you have an input
sequence and
you transform that through multi-head
attention
into another sequence right here okay
and then what you do is you take
each of these things and feed them
through a feed-forward
layer and if i as i understand it
this feed-forward layer is simply
you know a regular feed forward layer
that you would find in a neural network
and you pass them you pass these things
individually
so this here it's a vector you pass it
through here
and boom that becomes the next layer
representation this
thing right here you pass it through as
well boom
that becomes this one and so on right
you pass them
individually to get the next layer
representation
so this this part
right here the attention part it sort of
aggregates information and relates the
individual
items of the sequence to each other and
transforms them
into you know a new sequence where sort
of all the
every token can gather information from
every other token that's what the
attention mechanism does
that's step one in step two every token
is isolated every token is
for itself and the feed forward layer
simply determines
you know what's given one token given
token number one
what is you know given its
representation in this layer
what is the best representation for the
next layer okay
so that's token number one of the next
layer so the multi-head attention
is kind of relating uh
tokens to each other and the feed
forward layers
they are relating layers to each other
okay
so up here you would have the next
multi-head attention
layer so you can see the feed forward
layer as sort of
translating from one layer to the next
layer right getting
saying ah you come from this layer i'm
going to translate you
such that the next layer understands you
and that happens on a token by token
basis
now you can see this is it's always the
same feed forward layer for all the
tokens right the tokens are sort of
treated like a batch of
samples the idea of
this switch transformer and also of the
earlier mixture of
experts transformer is that
it might not be a good idea to have only
a single one right this is the only
feed forward layer it's the same for all
the tokens
it might actually be a good idea to have
a couple of them
that sort of specialize in different
things so what could that be you know in
a in a basic
world uh this could just be like
one for nouns and this could be a
feed-forward layer for verb
verbs tokens that are verbs tokens that
are adjectives
and sort of maybe here is like
punctuation tokens right
you might um think well if you are
a noun token the next layer might want
to look differently at you
than if you are a punctuation token
right
so this translation from one layer to
the next layer
can now happen dependent um
on what the token represents
right now we we of course first of all
we don't have these annotations and
second it's not necessarily that you
know we want to always divide it by noun
verb adjective punctuation ideally
we want to learn this routing so we
simply want to say
look instead of just one feet forward
layer
we uh give the model four feet forward
layer fee for layer one
two three and four and for each token
the model can decide to which of these
feed forward layer it sends the token to
so here you can see this is a token now
you know we are dealing with word pieces
let's just say the word
more i was like i was thoroughly
confused
by when i saw this like huh why does it
say more parameters
but here it's the string more right
and the string parameters and these are
in the vocabulary and they get an
embedding vector associated
with them uh so that's what's going on
here
then they go through self-attention as
you can see here both go through
self-attention and then each one of them
is routed to one of these four experts
now the
the one here the one on the left and the
one on the right these are the same
experts right they're just
duplicated uh visually here but these
would be
the same weight matrices in there so
you have four feet forward layers in
this layer
and each token can be routed to any one
of them
and this routing here this is learned so
in here you have a matrix they call it
like wr
and using wr you simply do an inner
product
of wr with your input right here let's
call that
h with your input h i guess they use h
for a different thing
i think they they call this x again so
you do this
with x and then you get
you get h which is your routing and then
you simply build a histogram you
normalize the histogram
i think with the softmax and that those
are your
routing weights so it's very much
like another attention mechanism except
that the queries um
this thing here these are like the
queries these are sort of the
queries of this attention mechanism
and this here these are the keys and the
values
so that's the keys and the values
of this attention mechanism uh the
queries are just learned so the queries
are not dynamically generated
and the keys and values they are not um
yeah it's a it's a weak analogy but you
can sort of
think of it like this so there is this
routing mechanism
um and it decides where a token gets
goes to now as you can see the router
is soft that means there is never a one
or a zero right here
there's always kind of a number in
between but they hard clip that
so they hard clip it they just route it
to the maximum as you can see here
number two is the maximum and they
just route it to number two they don't
route it proportionally or anything
they just to take rmax and they route it
through
they do multiply the output by the
actual number that they got out here so
if the router is unsure that the output
is less
uh if the router is sure the output is
more
but this hard routing is
what's the key right here and that means
you know before before you'd have one
feet forward layer
so any token that goes forward goes
through
one feet forward layer if you do a
mixture of experts in the classic sense
and you
route it in a soft way you now have four
feet forward layer so every token goes
through
four um of these computations
so you've basically multiplied the
amount of computation by
four because you've multiplied the
amount of parameters by four right you
have four times as many parameters
now when you do this argmax routing like
the switch transformer
you have multiplied the number of
parameters in your model by four
but any token will still only incur one
feed forward layer that means you keep
the amount of computation that you do
per forward pass
the same and that's that's sort of the
the key
right here so now they can scale up
massively the number of experts
while still keeping the amount of flops
the same
and notably you also don't need a any
data transfer in between
the experts uh every every expert
can be can you know receive their tokens
and then do their independent work so
you can efficiently shard this across
many many machines this is how
this looks so in
in this case you have uh three experts
and your sequences are of line of length
six so you wanna sort of route each
token there and there can be overflow
like every token is independently routed
so it can happen
something like this that a you know a
token like three token
gets routed to one expert but it only
has space for two tokens
and they have some tricks like they have
this capacity factor right here or they
can reroute
these are very much engineering things
which are important
but you know they don't change the sort
of
final final result now
i want to go down here where they have a
display of this
sharding uh more like an explanation of
the sharding which i think is
very uh illustrative
so how what do they essentially do
if you think of many machines you have
16 machines
so each little square here is one
machine
okay um here are the different ways
of how you can shard a model and model
sharding
you know we are not going to build a
machine anytime soon that can hold a
trillion parameters
just not gonna happen okay so you need
to somehow
shard the model or the data or both
and these are the different ways how you
can do it
so if you use data parallelism that is
the easiest that is also directly built
into
things like pi torch and so on what you
do
is so the top row shows how the model
weights
are split and the bottom row shows how
the data is split so how to read this
is when you do data parallelism
the weights are split such that each
of the 16 cores has the same weights you
see
so this these weights right here are the
same as these weights are the same
they're all the same so this is shorted
the data is run so that you take a data
set you take
a batch of data and now you distribute
this data point goes here this data
point goes here
this data point goes here and so on
you distribute the data and you
do the forward propagation and at the
end you sort of
gather them again right so you gather
them
together again if because you have to
you know
calculate your gradient okay
so that's data parallelism the model is
spread out
and if you want to do an update to the
model then you need to communicate
around
these weights okay so all these
different pieces have to then
communicate with each other when there's
a weight update
if you do data parallelism um here is
how the data split we've already seen
this so
one piece this piece of data is split
over 16 cores so you can see like this
core right here only has this little
piece of the data
and not all of the data on the other
hand
you can do model parallelism in model
parallelism you can see it's exactly the
other way around
namely that one core only has a little
piece of model
right and but every core gets all of the
data
so this data here the bottom row is data
all of the data the point here
is that if you do model parallelism
that's what you do
when the model itself doesn't fit right
over here the model fits
on your machine but not the whole batch
at the same time
model parallelism you do when the model
itself doesn't fit
what you have to do is you have to take
your data
right and you have to send it
sequentially
so maybe this is the first layer like
that's layer one weights
and then you have to compute layer one
and then you have to send it to layer
two
and so on so you have to send it
sequentially through
the through the sharding of the model
right because you wanna forward
propagate through all of the model
this is has very very much of a cost of
communication you can build very big
models but
it comes at a cost right at the end you
get your
y and you calculate your loss and you
backprop again
backwards through the whole thing you
can
mix them right you can do model and data
parallelism
so here you can see that the weights so
this is this is layer one weights layer
two layer three
layer four and here again you have layer
one layer two
layer three layer four and so on um
so you can mix the two in that you can
have
model and data parallelism if both your
model
and also your data don't fit uh in a
single
machine and you can see here that
the this upper left part receives
they receive the same data but this here
receives different
data right so you split your mini batch
into four different parts
and you send the first part up here
like that's data one you send that up
here and that goes through the model in
this
sequence sequential fashion uh you send
data to
right to here and so on so we mix the
two
now in expert and data parallelism
that's what they that's what they do in
the switch transformer
so this here is the switch transformer
and this here
over here will then that's the switch
transformer
one trillion so for the one trillion
model they actually need to mix
all of them but you want to
at you know if you can you want to avoid
model parallelism model parallelism is
really the thing
that kills you because of the very high
communication cost
so in the switch transformer they have
expert and
data parallelism what does it mean so
the top row is how the model weights are
split
and you can see the weights are split
but the different color means that
they're different
weights so here are weights number one
weights two
weights three weights four and so on
now we've already had this over here
right different weights in the model
parallelism case were split over
different machines
however
if you look at the data the data is also
split and the weights they're not the
same and these are exactly these experts
so experts this means
that you know this piece of data here
only goes to this expert
and then to the output this piece of
data right here
only goes to this expert and then to the
output
right there is no communication between
the
uh different experts whereas
here you have this super high
communication okay so you can see you
can scale up the experts
as you scale up your data as long as
each
shard of data is routed to only one
expert
and then of course you can mix the
expert model and data
parallelism um if you really if not even
a single expert fits on a machine
right if that's the case you need to
again
short you do model sharding on the
experts
all right so the switch transformer as i
said
this here is the switch transformer that
the
most of the paper is about and now we
can
dive into the results the results are
pretty spectacular
they mostly come compare as i said to t5
base and t5 large
and as you can see right here the switch
model
has significantly more parameters so 7.4
or here 26
a billion parameters compared to not
even a billion of t5
large yet the number of flops is matched
so they build models where the number of
flops for a forward prop is matched
but the the number of parameters
are higher so you know it is somewhat of
a fair comparison
right you have the same amount of
compute done per forward prop
and now we see what does it help to just
have
raw again in parameters and it turns out
it helps a lot you've
pro already seen that we get these
massive
speed ups massive sample efficiencies
over a dense model
you've probably so this we've looked at
exactly in the
in the intro they also have
benchmarks on oh let's see that's down
here they also have benchmarks on
multilingual
um on multi-lingual data set and you can
see in every
single language the switch transformer
gains on the dense transformer by quite
a bit so this is in this is log space
as you can see and it's quite impressive
actually and these gains are in time as
well as number of steps um
so that's pretty pretty cool
so as i as i said uh the
the trade-off here of course is that you
need more machines you need to actually
add more machines
and you can see this largest model that
they built
is this switch xxl which is matched in
flops
to trans2 to t5xxxl model
yet has many more parameters and beats
the t5 at log perplexity and
in as i understand in downstream tasks
by quite a bit
they also built this trillion parameter
model
it is not as good mainly
because they as i understand it they
just want to get to a trillion
parameters
and i think i think it's you know
training isn't really easy at that size
so they scale it down as you can see it
has less number of heads
less number of layers but the number of
experts are way up so that's how they
scale to a trillion
and the results aren't you know better
than the t5x xl
um which is impressive given that it has
less flops per token
however it is still worse than the
switch xxl
so the trillion parameter model um
it's still you know it's still not
everything to have a lot of parameters
you actually need to do good trade-offs
and here they've traded off too many
parameters
for you know less number of heads and
less number of layers
and that hurts again so
you know very very interesting stuff
right here the last thing
i want to look at is their tricks for
getting this
to work so they detail three tricks for
to work and they are
right here three tricks how they can do
this
and people before them have said no you
need at least two
experts otherwise it's instable so they
do
selective precision with the large
sparse models which means that
if for some of these computations
it you know it it pays off to do them in
higher precision
you don't want to send around these
float32
precision uh things you don't want to
send those from machine to machine
right so you have your input
you have your multi-head attention and
then
here again this is whatever x prime and
then you send
that to the experts right here are the
different experts
and then you send that back
and that's why okay now you
don't want this here is communication
cost
if you were to send around float 32
vectors that's a lot of data that you
have to transmit
so you'd rather send around 16-bit
precision
right as they do right here um however
if you do 16-bit precision
your you know the the whole machine
learning part doesn't work as well
so what they do is they do as soon as it
as a
as soon as a vector arrives here this is
in
16 bit they scale it up
they cast it to a 32 bit
vector they calculate using the 32-bit
vector
32 and then they cast it again to a
16-bit vector
to send it back and that seems to work
so they do
selective selectively
casting the precision up
and also they do selective dropout
that's down here
so they do expert dropout
which means they don't apply drop out to
the whole network
uniformly as you would do normally but
they say they can do a much larger
dropout
rate at expert layers and that makes a
bit of sense because the expert
each expert is only used very sparsely
so it makes sense to
up their dropout rate because you know
in the end you might
drop out as much signal from a sparsely
used expert
if you raise the dropout rate then
you do from a densely used layer in a
with a smaller dropout
rate and the last thing is that
they simply do better initialization so
they find
if they scale down the the initial scale
of the original transformer by a factor
of 10
that leads to a lot more stable training
it's astounding that after so many years
still something like initialization
can you know make or break such a model
that is just insane to see there's a lot
more to this paper they do a lot of
downstream
tasks they also talk a lot about you
know this is not only this model they do
a lot of optimizations under the hood uh
they use mesh tensorflow and so on
it's clear that a lot of work has gone
into this and
interestingly enough they can also
distill these models so what they can do
is they can take this large model and
they distill it
to a model that is as big as t5 base
a dense model so they go from a sparse
large model
and they distill it into a dense model
that is equivalent to t5
and they do outperform t5
if it were trained from scratch and they
gain
up to something like 30 percent so 30
of the gains they made from here to here
they can
retain by distilling it down they say
distill it down way over 90 95 percent
of the model which is also pretty
interesting
and you know pretty cool uh because then
you could
sort of distribute the trained models
around and people could use them
all right so that was it for me
definitely check out the paper and all
the experiments downstream tasks and so
on it's very cool paper
has a lot of cool experiments there's
code
at least pseudocode and that was it
thank you bye